Sophie! Sophie!
Komm rein!
Es reicht mit dem Theater.
In Kanada ist Josef Almeida
ohne seine Frau Beatrice im Stress.
Nein, dann geh irgendwo hin!
Aber mir reicht's jetzt.
Genug mit dem Theater.
* Sophie antwortet unverständlich. *
Ich habe einen Plan
und Dinge zu erledigen, Sophie.
Das Kindergartengetue
kannst du später machen.
In der letzten Folge
trieben die Almeidas ihr Geschäft
mit dem Motel weiter voran.
Zum Ende des Sommers verliess
Mutter Beatrice ihre Familie
und reiste für zweieinhalb Monate
in die Schweiz.
Ich vermisse Bea
schon jetzt irrsinnig.
Der Küstenimbiss an der Nordsee
ist endlich offen.
Und Sacha und Brigitte Kunz
servierten zum ersten Mal
Würste und Pommes frites.
Wir hatten heute einen guten Tag,
dafür, dass es der erste war.
Timo und Noemi kamen
mit ihrer Grossmutter in Dorum an.
Ein Wiedersehen
nach sechs langen Wochen.
Auf der Baustelle in Uruguay
hatte Susanne Althaus,
die ehemalige Pflegefachfrau,
Mühe mit dem Start.
Infusionen legen ist Präzisions-
arbeit, aber das hier noch mehr.
Bis ihre Ferienlodge steht,
lebt sie mit ihrem Mann Ruedi
in einem Wohncontainer.
Das ist fast wie im Skilager, was?
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Vogeltschirpen *
Ein Morgen wie jeder andere
und doch herrscht
ein klein wenig Ernüchterung.
Schon zwei Monate ist Susanne in
Uruguay und langsam realisiert sie,
wie weit die Heimat entfernt ist.
Bisher hatte sie ihre Familie
und die Freunde immer in der Nähe.
In ihrem grossen Haus
in Schüpbach im Emmental,
konnte sie alle um sich versammeln.
* Wehmütige exotische Musik *
Jetzt gibt es nur noch Ruedi
und diese 14 m2,
die viel Unwägbarkeiten
mit sich bringen.
Susanne dachte gar daran,
alles hinzuschmeissen.
Ja, an meinem Geburtstag.
Ich glaube,
der Tag vor dem Geburtstag
war einer der schlimmsten Tage.
Das Wetter war schlecht,
man ist auf so kleinem Raum.
Schlafraum, Küche, Wohnzimmer
und Büro - alles in einem.
Dann ist alles nass, es ist kalt.
Dann denkt man: "In der Schweiz
wäre das alles viel einfacher
und so anders."
Aber wir haben uns ja
dazu entschieden.
Nur weil es da so wüst war
und mir alles etwas zu viel war,
kann ich nicht sagen,
dass ich einfach nach Hause gehen.
Doch der
beginnende südamerikanische Frühling
brachte wieder Licht
in Susannes Gemüt.
Ich glaube, seither hatten wir keine
grösseren Stromunterbrüche mehr.
Unser Boiler funktioniert.
Es kamen viele Dinge
auf einmal zusammen.
U.a., dass das Wasser
nicht funktionierte.
Aber dann haben wir eine Wasch-
maschine besorgt, konnten waschen.
Seit drei Wochen
habe ich einen Backofen.
Und das ist super.
Mit dem Bau der Posada in Uruguay
wagen sie nicht zum ersten Mal
den Neuanfang.
Vor fünf Jahren befanden sich Ruedi
und seine Frau in einer Krise,
waren vorübergehend getrennt und
haben doch wieder zusammengefunden.
* Sanfte exotische Musik *
Seitdem wissen sie erst recht,
was sie aneinander haben.
Das gibt Kraft
für das gemeinsame Projekt.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Susanne
vermisst die Jungs sicher mehr.
Aber wenn ich sagen würde,
ich vermisse sie nicht,
würde ich sicher
einen Blödsinn erzählen.
Am Ende ist es die Familie,
es sind unsere Jungs,
die fehlen natürlich gewissermassen,
das ist klar.
Noch ist der Weg weit,
bis ihre Posada steht.
Es sind kleine Dinge, die für Susanne
einen grossen Unterschied machen.
So.
Jetzt kann dieses Brot aufgehen
und backen.
Ende Oktober im Osten Kanadas.
In der Provinz Nova Scotia
verabschiedet sich der Indian Summer.
* Pfeifender Wind *
In Tatamagouche bereitet Josef
Almeida das Motel für Halloween vor.
Seit gut vier Wochen
ist er mit den Kindern alleine.
* Hausklingel *
(Krächzende Stimme)
Enter at your own risk.
* Gruseliges Lachen *
Ich glaube,
jetzt kann Halloween kommen.
Jetzt stellen wir
noch die Süssigkeiten bereit.
Das ist wohl das Wichtigste.
Mir bedeutet Halloween
eigentlich nicht viel,
aber dem muss man sich
halt auch anpassen.
Das gehört halt auch dazu.
Das ist das, was wir
in der Schweiz auch wollen, nicht?
* Türklingel *
Geht's dir gut mit deinem Arm?
Hast du einen neuen Gips?
Ausgerechnet jetzt, wo
Mutter Beatrice in der Schweiz ist,
hat sich Sohn André
den Arm gebrochen.
Hoi.
Robin, komm! Gib mir kurz
deine Tasche! Hast du Hausaufgaben?
Hausaufgaben?
- Nein.
André ist nach dem Unterricht
auf dem Spielplatz gestürzt.
In der Schule haben wir Stangen,
die in einer Reihe stehen.
Ich versuchte,
zur fünften zu springen.
Mit der rechten Hand habe ich sie
erwischt, nicht aber mit der linken.
Deshalb bin ich
auf die linke Hand gefallen.
So habe ich mir den Arm gebrochen.
Er konnte auf der Krankenstation in
Tatamagouche nicht behandelt werden.
Für den Gips musste er
bis in die Provinzhauptstadt Halifax.
Das ist schon blöd.
Man muss 2 Std. lang in
die nächste grössere Stadt fahren -
dann auch wieder 2 Std. zurück.
Im Spital gibt es doch
auch ziemlich lange Wartezeiten.
Und, ja ...
Bea und ich haben natürlich vieles
geplant und zuvor organisiert.
Aber solche Momente ...
kann man gar nicht planen.
Die Gästebetreuung im Motel
übergab Josef einer Mitarbeiterin.
Sophie und Robin
brachte er bei Schulfreunden unter.
Also, nimm es an den Platz!
Von Andrés Unfall hat Beatrice
in der Backstube erfahren.
Mehr als 5'000 km entfernt produziert
sie Anisguetzli: zentnerweise!
Zusammen mit ihrem Mann Josef
hat sie entscheiden,
dass sie das Geschäft mit dem Süssge-
bäck trotz Auswanderung weiterführt.
Man sitzt hier etwas
auf dem Trockenen.
Man wartet auf Nachrichten,
was los ist.
Und ...
"Ich habe jetzt keine Zeit" und so.
Das ist also schon
eine blöde Situation.
Man ist hier und denkt: "Mist!"
Wir sind sonst so ein gutes Team,
gemeinsam schaffen wir immer alles.
Es wäre jetzt so einfach gewesen:
Einer hätte ins Spital gehen,
der andere zu Hause bleiben können.
Auch wenn Beatrice
es sich anders wünscht -
momentan kann sie ihren Sohn
nur aus der Ferne trösten.
In Kanada hat André keine Zeit,
an seinen gebrochenen Arm zu denken.
Up to you.
- Ich habe keine Tüte.
Du teilst sie mit Robin und André.
Die Kinder wollen zur Halloween-Tour
und haben sich mit ihren Freunden
aus der Schule verabredet.
Da, Robin, schnell!
Du hast die grösste Tüte.
Bye-bye.
Die nächsten Stunden ziehen sie
gemeinsam durch die Nachbarschaft.
Trick or treat - Süsses oder Saures
heisst es auch im Motel.
After that you can take it.
(Krächzende Stimme)
Enter at your own risk.
* Gruseliges Lachen *
Thank you.
- From Switzerland?
Bye-bye, guys.
- Thank you.
Das Motel der Almeidas
ist diesem Abend sehr beliebt -
trotz Nebensaison.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Ist das Auto offen?
Nein, das Auto ist abgeschlossen.
An der Nordsee zieht es Timo und
Noemi mit ihrer Grossmutter ans Meer.
Jetzt ist es offen.
Falco! So ist's ein feiner Junge.
Sie wollen den Imbiss sehen.
Seit zehn Tagen
sind ihre Eltern dort die Chefs.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es aussieht.
Bestimmt sehr gut.
Und ich freue mich
auf eine Currywurst.
Darauf habe ich so lange gewartet.
Timo kennt sich in Dorum bereits aus.
Viele Jahren lang kam er mit
seinen Eltern hierher in die Ferien.
Timo, jetzt muss ich ...
(Beide) ... links.
Dann sind wir bald da.
- Dann sind es nur noch 30 ...
Der 13-Jährige
ist nicht ganz unschuldig daran,
dass seine Eltern
nun einen Imbiss besitzen.
Es ist schon Papis Ding,
so etwas zu machen.
(Noemi) Ich hätte es mir
nicht vorstellen können.
Es war ja meine Idee.
- Ach ja?
Ich habe das Schild gesehen.
- Ach, das meinst du.
(Noemi)
Jetzt bin ich dir irgendwie dankbar.
Kinder, wo muss ich parken?
- Geradeaus.
Noch immer geradeaus, ja?
Hier irgendwo, nehme ich an.
- (Timo) Ich sehe unseren Wagen.
(Noemi) Ich auch.
- (Timo) Hier links.
Dann ist es so weit.
Timo, Noemi und Susanne sehen den
Küsten-Imbiss zum ersten Mal in echt.
Einmal Pommes Spezial
und sechs Chicken Nuggets.
Currywurst mit Pommes und Mayo.
- Das sieht super aus.
Falco.
Wirklich gut, sehr schön.
- Frikadelle, Pommes?
Hallo.
- Hallo. Ein Slush, oder?
Ja und Pommes.
Und eine Currywurst für Nana.
Schatz, hier.
Einmal Pommes Spezial
und sechs Chicken Nuggets.
Doch Brigitte und Sacha haben keine
Zeit, sich um die Kinder zu kümmern.
Der Andrang ist zu gross.
Wie war das jetzt? Mit Mayo?
- Das bekommt mein Mann.
Danke.
- Guten Appetit!
Du musst mir noch
Wechselgeld bringen.
2er, 1er, 50er, 20er und 10er.
Je zwei?
- Je eine.
Und reichen 30 Brötchen?
Ja, bring sie einfach mal.
Du brauchst die nicht abzuzählen.
Tschüss!
- Tschüss, bis später.
Susanne muss sich mit dem Essen
noch etwas gedulden.
Zuerst kommt die Imbissbude,
dann die Wurst.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Nur 60 km vom neuen Daheim
der Emmentaler entfernt
trifft man auf Schweizer Geschichte.
* Exotische Hackbrettmusik *
Ruedi und Susanne
gönnen sich eine Pause.
Sie besuchen Nueva Helvecia
zusammen mit Alex,
ihrer Auswanderungsberaterin.
Vor 150 Jahren
waren Schweizer der Armut entkommen
und hatten sich
in Uruguay niedergelassen.
Heute ist das ganz anders.
Ruedi und Susanne können hier
einen Traum verwirklichen.
Dann geht die Strasse nach rechts.
Ah, er wartet schon.
Auf Wunsch der Auswanderer hat Alex
einen Hundezüchter ausfindig gemacht.
* Der Hundezüchter
spricht spanisch. *
Daniel züchtet eine ganz spezielle
Rasse, den Cimarrón Uruguayo.
Ein Hund,
der den beiden besonders gut gefällt.
* Bellen *
Einen Hund zu haben
war für uns schon immer ein Thema.
Aber als wir beide
unregelmässig gearbeitet haben,
wären wir dem Hund
nicht gerecht geworden.
Na?
- Ja. Du bist ein Schöner.
Jetzt sieht es etwas anders aus.
Wenn wir draussen auf dem Campo
sind, gibt es etwas Sicherheit.
Ein Hund macht auch Eindruck.
Deshalb möchten wir einen grossen.
Wenn ich einen Hund möchte,
dann wirklich einen grossen.
Ist gut? Nein,
ich kann dich nicht rausnehmen.
Ja, wir machen ihnen nichts. Na?
Die beiden Welpen
wurden vor neun Wochen geboren.
Wenn sie ausgewachsen sind,
wiegen sie gut 45 kg.
Oh, jö!
Du bist ja ein süsser Kerl.
* Der Hundezüchter
spricht spanisch. *
(Alexandra übersetzt.)
Es waren elf Junge. - Ah.
* Der Hundezüchter
spricht spanisch. *
Die werden so gross wie der Vater.
Ja, so.
Halt kurz still, kleiner Junge!
* Signalton *
Na, komm.
Willst du ein wenig lecken?
* Der Hundezüchter
spricht spanisch. *
Morgen kommt jemand.
Wenn ihr einen nehmt,
solltet ihr entscheiden welchen.
Dich.
- Oder dich?
Jetzt entscheidet Frau Häuschen.
Ich finde beide putzig.
Es ist schwierig.
Ihr seid beide süss.
Beide sind süss ...
... jetzt noch. In einem Jahr
werden sie Maschinen sein.
Also, ich finde den hellen schön.
Also.
- Also, ich finde beide niedlich.
Den.
- Das stimmt für mich.
Lasst irgendwas da ... einen Hunni.
Dann rufe ich irgendwann an,
wann ihr in abholen wollt.
Schau hier, Mama. Hoppla.
Bald haben sie
ein neues Familienmitglied.
Fehlt nur noch der passende Name.
Tschüss zusammen.
Besondere Hundenamen mit C:
Caddy, Cadillac, Cain, Cairo.
Cerveza.
- Cerveza? Cerveza!
* Alexandra lacht. *
Cognac.
In Turbenthal im Kanton Zürich
bereitet Beatrice
den nächsten Markttag vor.
Die Bärchen.
Fast 1'000 kg Teig
verarbeitet sie während der Saison.
Dafür steht sie
von früh bis spät in der Backstube.
Das ist auch etwas eintönig,
die Kinder sind auch nicht da.
Man bereitet kein Mittagessen vor,
macht keine Hausaufgaben mit ihnen -
das fehlt schon etwas. Das ist ...
... eine etwas komische Situation,
so alleine.
Wenn man alles alleine stemmen muss.
Ein Drittel der Kekse
liefert sie an einen Grossverteiler.
Den Rest verkauft sie selbst.
20 verschiedene Märkte
besucht sie in der Deutschschweiz.
* Sanft gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Wir wussten nicht,
wie lange es dauert, bis wir ...
... auswandern können.
Alle Märkte sind angemeldet.
Bei gewissen Märkten dauert es
lange, bis man einen Stand erhält.
Das ist alles organisiert,
es funktioniert alles.
Ich denke,
wir machen das noch einmal.
Sophie! Sophie!
Komm rein!
Es reicht mit dem Theater.
In Kanada ist Ehemann Josef
immer wieder aufs Neue gefordert.
Nein, dann geh irgendwo hin!
Aber mir reicht's jetzt.
Genug mit dem Theater.
* Sophie antwortet unverständlich. *
Ich habe einen Plan
und Dinge zu erledigen, Sophie.
Das Kindergartengetue
kannst du später machen.
Das Problem:
ein Streit unter Geschwistern.
Alle Kollegen durften schon
auf Andrés Gips unterschreiben -
nur Sophie noch nicht.
André, Robin, ihr müsst jetzt gehen.
Zum Coiffeur.
So, go to Imindy.
Du kannst auch alles einfach
hinwerfen. Das ist schon gut.
Josef muss nicht nur
die eigenen Kinder managen,
sondern auch deren Freunde, die sich
im Motel wie zu Hause fühlen.
In diesem Moment fehlt Bea,
die etwas ...
... strenger ist und etwas mehr
Disziplin ins Ganze bringen würde.
Ich bin da eher etwas ...
generös, sage ich mal.
Das könntest du kopieren, bitte.
Das hier. Hier, da.
Ist es jetzt in Ordnung, Sophie?
* Sophie antwortet leise. *
Noch immer nicht?
Ach, sei doch nachsichtig.
Er hat es doch nur vergessen.
Er macht es
bestimmt nicht mit bösen Absichten.
Längst zählt er die Tage,
bis seine Frau wieder da ist.
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Erst wasche ich meine Hände.
An der Nordsee
muss Susanne nicht nur Wechselgeld,
sondern auch Brötchen
für den Imbiss organisieren.
Nicht anfassen,
bevor du die Hände gewaschen hast!
Ich will es nur öffnen.
- Ich sage es dir nur.
Diese Brötchen?
- Ja.
Ich habe sie bereits gezählt.
- Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Elf. 13.
- 25.
25.
- 27.
40.
- Nein, 40 sind zu viele.
Mama hat gesagt,
wir müssen nicht zählen.
* Tiefe, marschierende Bläserklänge *
* Marschierende Bläser-
und Orgelklänge *
Genau für solche Jobs
wäre eigentlich der grosse Sohn Kevin
eingeplant gewesen.
Doch der hat sich umentschieden.
Er will nicht mehr nach Dorum kommen.
Ich glaube, sie versuchen das so
lange wie möglich alleine zu machen.
Sonst müssen sie
jemanden einstellen.
Dich.
- Was, mich?
Ja.
- Nein.
Nein, ich bin nicht dafür geeignet.
Ich mache gerne alles andere.
Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass ich das kann.
Dank dem spontanen Einsatz
von Timo und Susanne
kommen die Brötchen
gerade noch rechtzeitig.
Das Münzgeld aber entspricht
nicht ganz Brigittes Vorstellungen.
Oh, nicht diesen 2er.
Ich brauche keine roten.
Das hast du aber nicht gesagt.
Du sagtest, von jedem einen.
Hast du auch 1er?
- Nein.
Wir haben alles genommen.
- Doch.
Wenn ich den Auftrag erhalte,
von allen einen zu bringen,
dann heisst das für mich
auch von allen einen.
Die werden im Laufe der Zeit
auch gebraucht.
Hier ist ein 1er.
- Ist gut. Super.
Auch Ein- und Zwei-Cent-Münzen
hat Susanne mitgebracht.
Aber die
braucht ihre Tochter so gut wie nie.
Wir sind teilweise etwas am Limit,
je nachdem, wie viele Leute es hat.
Jetzt ist gut, sie kommen
vereinzelt, das ist machbar.
Zuvor hatte es eine Schlange,
dann ist es schwierig.
Dann wäre es alleine nicht machbar.
Der erste Nachmittag gestern
war sehr ruhig,
deshalb
konnte es einer alleine machen.
Ab September, Oktober
wird das wohl wieder möglich sein.
Aber ich denke, Juni, Juli,
August ... Nein, wirklich nicht.
2.50.
Und dann bekommt Susanne
sie doch noch: ihre Currywurst.
Lecker.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonmusik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Vogelzwitschern *
* Exotische Musik *
Bis Ruedi und Susanne
in Uruguay mit ihrer Posada abheben,
gibt es noch viel zu tun.
* Exotische Strandklänge *
Die Aktionswoche eines
Schwimmbad-Händlers in Montevideo
wollen sie nutzen
und einen Pool aussuchen -
für sich und ihre zukünftigen Gäste.
Hola.
- Hola. Buon dia.
Alex. Hola.
Einmal mehr
unterstützt sie Alex dabei.
Die Bassingrösse.
So, wie der draussen.
Der ist zu klein.
- Es muy chico.
Heute morgen habe ich im Internet
etwas recherchiert.
Mich interessiert sicher der Filter.
Alles andere lernt man.
Also, ich setze mich zum ersten Mal
mit einem Swimmingpool auseinander.
Aber Dr. Google
weiss unglaublich viel.
Der Verkäufer schlägt Flavia vor,
ein Fertigpool
mit 30'000 l Fassungsvermögen.
Diese Woche
ist das Becken im Sonderangebot.
Die effektiven Kosten sind jetzt,
dank dem 20-%-Rabatt, 13'200 Fr.
Also ... das liegt im Budget.
Die Kosten für ihr Projekt
hat Ruedi genau berechnet.
Knapp zwei Jahre können sie
ohne Einkommen überleben.
Welche wollt ihr denn?
Beige oder blau?
(Beide) Blau.
Liegt das drin?
- Ja, wir brauchen einen Pool.
Ja, ja.
Mir gefällt es hier.
Es sieht auch gut aus.
Wir werden wohl hier verhandeln.
Was meinst du?
Ja.
- Ich muss immer die Chefin fragen.
Der Eindruck ist gut.
Wir unterschreiben.
Okay.
Bueno. Lo piden.
Eh?
- Lo piden. Lo segnan.
Pool gut, alles gut.
Das Geschäft
scheint für beide aufzugehen.
Wenn du noch 200 hast,
Frau Häuschen, haben wir 1'000.
* Glockenschläge *
In Wil im Kanton St. Gallen
bereiten sich die Händler
auf den Othmarsmarkt vor.
Auch Beatrice hat dort einen Stand.
Schon als Kind begleitete sie
ihre Mutter zum Kekseverkauf.
Seit zwölf Jahren bietet sie das
Süssgebäck auf eigene Rechnung an.
Ich mag das.
So, wie ich es jetzt mache ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Das hier ist alles
ein wenig auf meinem Mist gewachsen.
Das ist nur meins.
Ihre Waren
laufen nicht überall gleich gut.
Je nach Ort und Witterung
ist der Umsatz ganz verschieden.
Hätten Sie gerne eine Tüte?
- Nein, ist gut.
Kein Markttag ist wie der andere.
Voilà. Merci.
Auf gewissen Märkten
läuft es sehr gut.
Da kann man 2'000-3'000 machen.
Auf anderen Märkten
sind es ein paar Hundert.
Das ist eine super Sache.
Natürlich ist es nicht so,
dass es aufs letzte Geld ankommt.
Aber ...
... es ist finanziell
sicher eine Hilfe.
Das macht 40 Fr., bitte.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Rezept mit.
Hier drauf sind meine Temperaturen.
- Vielen Dank.
Falls Sie noch eine Frage haben,
rufen Sie mich an.
Das Geld von den Keksen können
Almeidas in Kanada gut gebrauchen.
Auch wenn sie ihr Umsatzziel im Motel
bereits erreicht haben.
Josef will weiter investieren
und den Keller unter dem Hauptgebäude
ausbauen.
Nachbar Charles hilft ihm dabei
und kümmert sich um die Elektrik.
(Englisch)
Ich erhalte viele Anfragen
von Leuten,
die die Räume für Anlässe
oder Geburtstage mieten möchten.
Leider habe ich aber
nur eine Toilette, die funktioniert.
Als es vor ein paar Jahren
einen Wasserschaden gab,
wurden diese hier
in Mitleidenschaft gezogen.
Ich liess bereits
alle Leitungen ersetzen.
Auch das Elektrische.
Alles ist auf dem neusten Stand.
Jetzt warte ich eigentlich
nur noch auf den Trockenbauer,
damit die Wände gemacht werden.
Der Handwerker vertröstet Josef
aber immer wieder aufs Neue.
We'll be in touch.
- (Josef) We'll be.
Dabei wäre jetzt
die ideale Zeit für den Umbau.
Seit es kühler geworden ist,
kommen kaum noch Touristen.
* Pfeifender Wind,
melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Wir schalten das Wasser und die
Heizung aus, um Energie zu sparen.
Anders als der Vorbesitzer
möchte Josef das Motel
nicht komplett schliessen.
Dennoch macht er über den Winter
acht Zimmer dicht.
Diesmal beauftragt er den Klempner.
In Zukunft möchte Josef
das selbst machen können.
Here.
- Yes, that's it.
* Autohupe *
Die Männer müssen
sämtliche Wasserleitungen entleeren,
damit sie bei Frost nicht platzen.
Im und unter dem Gebäude.
Das wäre das Schlimmste,
dass man hier rein, drunter muss.
(Josef) Da haben kleine Menschen
einen Vorteil, was?
Gefriert es hier überhaupt?
- Ja, im Winter wird es kalt.
Es wird bis zu -20 °C,
dann gefriert es hier.
Das Wasser kommt hier rein.
- (Josef) Jawohl.
Ist das das Wasser von draussen,
das er abgestellt hat?
Das muss man hier abklemmen?
- Ja.
Ja. Dieses Rohr läuft wieder zurück
Richtung Stadt.
Da ist ein Loch drin,
wo das rausläuft.
(Josef) Okay, ich verstehe.
Die Idee ist, dass wir es
wieder einschalten würden,
wenn sich genügend Leute
anmelden würden.
Also, wenn die restlichen acht Räume
reserviert würden -
für ein Hockeyturnier
oder sonst einen Anlass.
Dann müsste ich mir überlegen,
ob wir es wieder einschalten.
Okay. Es geht wieder raus.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Ich bedanke mich.
- Kein Problem.
In ein paar Wochen
beginnt der Winter -
entweder mit Gästen im Motel
oder mit mehr Ruhe,
als Almeidas lieb ist.
Schon wieder etwas erledigt.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Möwenschreie *
Am Kutterhafen in Dorum-Neufeld
ist es ruhig.
Sehr ruhig.
* Verspielte Orgelklänge *
Ein Teil der Buden
ist sogar geschlossen.
Öffnen sie gar nicht?
- Nein, vergiss es.
Nicht, oder?
- Die beiden kommen sicher nicht.
Wir wollen und können
nicht geschlossen lassen.
Irgendwann kommt vielleicht doch
noch jemand vom Camping oder so.
Dann ... sieht es vielleicht
etwas schlecht aus,
wenn wir als "Neulinge"
geschlossen haben.
Dann werden Sprüche kommen wie:
"Die haben es nicht nötig."
Es ist auch schade.
Deshalb haben wir bis Ende Oktober
bei jedem Wetter geöffnet.
Moin.
- Hallo.
* Schleppende Bassklänge *
* Verspielte Orgelklänge *
Seit einem Monat
stehen Sacha und Brigitte
tagein, tagaus hinter dem Grill.
Oft mehr als 10 Std.
Sicher ist es hart.
Es ist sicher keine ...
Ich sage mal,
es ist keine einfache Zeit,
diese Sieben-Tage-Wochen,
die wir bis Ende Oktober haben.
Aber wir sind gerne da und erhalten
viele positive Rückmeldungen.
Das stellt auf und so freut man sich
jeden Tag, arbeiten zu gehen.
Ja.
Wir müssen unsere Work-Life-Balance
schon noch etwas suchen.
Ja, ich denke, das braucht
seine Zeit. Aber das wird schon.
* Verspielte Orgelklänge *
Zu Hause packt Tochter Noemi
fürs erste Training
im neuen Cheerleading-Verein.
Der Sport ist ihr Ein und Alles.
Die letzten Jahre
ging sie in Basel zu den Unicorns.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn ich hier kein Cheerleading
hätte machen können,
wäre das schon blöd gelaufen.
Ich bin froh,
dass es das hier auch gibt.
Das Wetter ist zu schlecht.
Sacha und Brigitte haben den Imbiss
für heute geschlossen.
Das Gute daran: Sie können mit Noemi
zum Training bei den Ice Angels.
Es tut auch gut, wenn man mal
etwas früher Feierabend machen kann.
Das ist für uns auch Erholung,
wir kommen mal aus dem Wagen raus.
Wir können etwas Kräfte sparen
für die nächsten langen Tage,
die sicher wieder kommen werden.
* Signalton *
Mama. Lara ist übrigens im Spital.
Lara von den Ice Angels?
- Ja.
Okay.
- Morgen hätten sie einen Auftritt.
Ihnen fehlen jetzt Leute
und ich müsste einspringen.
Aber ich weiss halt nicht,
ob die Zeit reicht,
dass ich das heute
alles lernen kann. Und ja ...
Ah!
Hallo.
- Hallo.
(Brigitte) Ihr dürft euch
auch wieder loslassen.
Hi, Indira, alles gut? Hi.
Mit Indira ist sie seit Januar
am Schreiben, am Telefonieren.
Ja.
Da haben sich zwei gefunden.
Sie haben sich lange nicht gesehen -
seit Februar, als wir hier waren.
So, die Damen. Auf geht's!
Nun muss Noemi zeigen,
ob sie mit dem Niveau
der anderen Mädchen mithalten kann.
* Reggaeton-Musik im Hintergrund *
Okay. Ready?
Ready.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
One, two ...
Es ist schon vergleichbar.
Aber ich glaube, gewisse Ausdrücke,
Namen, sind hier anders.
Logisch, man muss sich
immer wieder daran gewöhnen.
Das ist ein Teamsport,
man ist Teil des Teams, der Gruppe.
Die sind z.T.
schon jahrelang zusammen.
Das braucht natürlich
schon etwas ...
... Feingefühl und so,
bis es wieder ganz funktioniert.
... three, four, five,
six, seven, eight.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Das Fangen macht Noemi noch Probleme.
Reicht es für den Auftritt?
Auf geht's!
* Gemächliche Akkordeonmusik *
Wochen später in Uruguay:
Der erste Bungalow steht,
vier weitere fehlen noch.
75 m3 Beton,
600 m2 Holzplatten
sowie 300 kg Schrauben
haben die Emmentaler schon verbaut.
Oft alleine, aber immer wieder
auch mit Helfern aus der Schweiz.
Selbst die neuen Freunde
packen mit an.
Marc, ein ausgewanderter Zürcher,
unterstützt die beiden, wo er kann.
Ging das zu schnell.
- Es klingelt.
Ah, es ist Luki. Hallo.
Hallo Janet. Hallo.
- Hallo.
So toll.
Der jüngste Sohn meldet sich
mit einer Kollegin aus der Heimat.
Tschau.
- Hallo zusammen.
Wo seid ihr da unten?
- Im Bungalow.
In unserem Haus.
- Willst du es mal zeigen?
Das ist der Eingang. Hier
ist das erste Wohnzimmerfenster.
Dann gehen wir
ins erste Schlafzimmer.
So.
Hier kommt ein Schrank hin.
Und hier gibt es
das zweite Schlafzimmer.
Das ist riesig.
- Ich versuche noch, hinauszugehen.
Das ist die Terrasse.
Überdacht.
Euch geht's gut, ja?
- Ja, uns geht's gut.
Ja?
- Danke. Ja, uns geht's gut.
Super.
Merci. Tschüss, ihr beiden.
Ciao ciao.
(Beide) Ciao.
Als die ersten Auswanderer
gegangen sind,
hatten sie ja mit niemandem Kontakt.
Sie haben ihre Familie und
ihre Leute einfach zurückgelassen.
Wir sind zwar gegangen,
aber ich kann mich bei ihnen melden,
wir sehen einander -
auch, wie es dem anderen geht.
Klar, man spürt es nicht.
Aber man sieht es.
Und es ist gut so.
Und dann rollt der Bagger an.
Die ersten Gäste
kommen zwar erst in einem Jahr,
doch schon jetzt will Ruedi den
Swimmingpool installieren lassen.
(Spanisch)
Der gelernte Bauschreiner
in der Zuschauerrolle.
Tipptopp,
das gefällt mir.
Sie hier wissen wohl auch,
was Sache ist. Von daher ...
Ich glaube, das ist gut.
Langsam aber stetig
geht es auf der Baustelle voran.
Und mit jedem weiteren Tag
fühlt sich Susanne in Uruguay
ein wenig mehr daheim.
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
In Bremerhaven
ist das Training zu Ende.
Noemi?
Ich fand das Training gut,
aber anstrengend.
Mir hat es heute auch gut gefallen.
Vergiss deine Bedenken, das könnte
für den Auftritt nicht reichen.
Wenn es morgen zeitlich passt,
wäre es gut, wenn du kommst.
Ansonsten:
ab und zu ein bisschen ruhiger.
Dann würdet ihr noch mehr schaffen.
Aber für das erste richtige Training
nach den Sommerferien war das super.
Ich habe Schweizer Schokolade dabei.
Der Einstand im neuen Cheerleading-
Verein ist Noemi gelungen.
(Alle) Tschüss.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Indira, kommst du morgen
nach dem Auftritt mit uns mit?
Ich schreibe deiner Mama noch.
- Ja, schreib am besten.
Mache ich. Tschüss.
Meine Lieblingsschokolade
ist noch übrig.
Und gleich alle Kalorien wieder ...
- Nein, nein, nur eine Reihe.
Also lass mich!
* Verspielte Akkordeonmusik *
Samstagmorgen in Kanada,
kurz vor 7 Uhr.
Macht etwas vorwärts, Kinder!
Wir müssen wirklich gehen.
Robin muss zum Eishockey.
André kommt mit - trotz Armbruch.
* Türklingel *
Ist das meine Angestellte?
Yes, it's me.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
Robin, dein Arm noch.
Ich möchte, dass du den anziehst.
So weiss man, dass du zum Team
gehörst und sieht deinen Namen.
Wenn ich nicht auf dem Eis bin,
ist mir das etwas peinlich.
Das muss es kein bisschen.
Du gehörst ja zum Team.
Nein, Papi, das geht nicht.
- Ist gut, André?
Ich habe aber keine Lust.
Ja, wir schauen nachher.
Ist das von Robin? - Ja.
Bitte steigt ins Auto ein!
Bye, Claire.
Normalerweise
macht immer Josef das Frühstück,
auch wenn nur noch
wenige Gäste hier sind.
Heute übernimmt das
für einmal Claire.
See you later.
- Bye-bye.
* Türklingel *
Beim Schnuppertraining
im Eishockeyverein
möchte Josef
seine Buben nicht alleine lassen.
Dennoch ist er in Gedanken
immer wieder im Motel.
Das ist für mich auch ein Prozess -
loslassen lernen ...
... mich eigentlich um das Wichtige
im Leben zu kümmern.
Robin!
Robin, don't do that!
Robin, no!
Josef hat mit seinen Kindern
bald das zweite Drittel
ohne Beatrice gemeistert.
Nun hofft er, dass das Leben keine
weiteren Überraschungen bereithält.
Der Timeout in der Liebe
fordert Josef schon genug.
Der Mensch ist wohl nicht
zum Alleinsein gemacht -
ich zumindest nicht.
Bea fehlt halt immer.
* Trillerpfeife *
Herbststürme und Hochwasser
an der Nordsee in der nächsten Folge.
Vorsicht.
Die Baselbieter bringen
den Imbisswagen ins Winterlager.
Keine Currywurst,
keine Bratwurst, keine Pommes mehr.
In Uruguay kommt Flavia.
* Regelmässige Piepsen *
Bravo.
Susanne ist seit Tagen
beim Isolieren.
Ja, ja, das ist so Kleinarbeit.
Und Hund Che
erobert sein neues Daheim.
* Bellen *
Langersehntes Wiedersehen in Kanada.
Mami!
Beatrice kommt endlich heim.
Und im Motel hat Josef
eine Überraschung für seine Frau.
Das ist megaschön.
# U si stige i Flüger,
# flüge mit de Vögu furt,
chöme nümme hei.
Deshalb sind wir gekommen.
Ich geniesse es in vollen Zügen,
wenn ich kann.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
* Entspannte Reggae-Musik *
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2020